kyle gibson he's a sinker ball pitcher
that's the two scene fastball he'll
throw some four
seam fastballs and as well as sliders so
here comes betts i don't know
two bet swings and misses
now faces seeger with the bases empty
swings at the first pitch launches it to
right center field gallows going back
corey seeger long ball and the dodgers
lead just like that
and go figure it's on the first pitch
that he sees his ninth home run of the
season
tying him with muncie and bellinger
muncie at
second base now pollock up there with
two away
pollock couldn't hold up and that
strikeout ends the first the dodgers
will settle for the run on the seeger
homer
fourth start of the season for tony
gonzalen in a spotless
line so far no runs in 14 and two thirds
so base runner on to get things started
swinging a miss on that split change one
out
three-hitter jose trevino with a man at
first and one gone
sets and deals a payoff trevino swings
and misses
throw from smith is there and a strike
him out throw him out to finish the
first
so two up two down here in the second
and up comes will smith
gibson fires 2-1 smith swings it's a fly
ball to left field sending chew back
on the track at the wall it's gone
will smith the home run and the dodgers
with solo shots in each of the first two
innings making it two nothing
does have six stolen bases absolutely a
threat to be going
bets running go down to second a good
one and they got him
first time this year he's been gunned
down
well that was a great throw that's our
second
let's try him out and throw him out
double play one for each club muncie at
first as bellinger stands in
gibson comes home bellinger swings it's
a fly by to right field gallows going
back out of room and gone
and the dodgers have it more home runs
in august of 2020
than any national league team has ever
hit in any month
it's bellinger's 10th back-to-back games
with home runs for him
now he walks two more to the bases with
nobody out he's got his work cut out for
him here
solac is not going to give him an easy
out
that one all the way to the backstop and
here comes tavares he'll score
everybody else moves up the base and the
rangers are on the board it's four to
one
base has loaded nobody out trevino the
three-hitter stands in
infield fly rule in effect godzilla gets
the first out of the inning
now it's gallow dodgers still in front
4-1 it's a big pitch
early in this game base has loaded one
out 3-2 to gallow
he struck him out a fast ball to the
bottom of the knees
gallow not happy about the call from
marvin hudson neither is chris woodward
and
boy according to the uh on-screen strike
zone there they have grounds for that
argument
to todd frazier another payoff he
struck him out with the slider to finish
off the inning
it gives mookie betts a two out chance
here in the fourth
shoots one off gibson's glove and into
center field for an rbi hit
smith into score lux headed for third
and they lead 5-1 as they've scored it
all four innings now
runners at first and third one out for
jeff mathis who singled sharply to left
his first time up
his fault here out to center but not
going to go
far enough pollock tracks it down he'll
make the catch
tagging at third kind of fallout he
scores and leone gets to second base so
a sac fly
for mathis and it's five to two second
and third one out infield comes in as
bets takes a 2-2
he reaches out and flips it into right
center field
this should bring home another rbi for
him
it does as taylor steps on home and it's
6-2
new seaver trying to add on two on two
out eighth inning runners that take off
yank down the line base hit right field
smith into score on a single from corey
seeger and the dodgers lead at 7-2
one-on-one out here's ronald guzman
lined right into the defense lux back to
second a double play
that double play that was about as
nonchalant a double play as i've ever
seen
now the dodgers trying to win their
ninth series and trying to remain
unbeaten in their 12 series this season
two with the bases empty and two out
ground ball right side that's lux and
that's the game that's the series the
dodgers have taken
another and they've won 15 of their last
18 overall
it's an amazing dominant year from the
los angeles dodgers now starting to
click on all cylinders when they get
justin turner back
they've got max muncie swinging the bat
well cody bellinger swinging it well of
course
betts and seeger are doing their job
they're now at a plus
90 run differential that's good